[Music]
hey guys welcome back to across the
melting y'all I went through man a
[ __ ] scary ass time with a with
another crackhead recently with another
crackhead kid with another crack know
what the first crackhead story was the
one at barbell where that guy try to
break in the car when I was in there oh
this is like a same type of thing with
the guy with the [ __ ] red ass I so
anyways like I go and take my dog out
right like my my dogs are just chillin
playing they're going poopoo all that
and I see this guy he walks up like she
just looks like a regular like thug like
beanie [ __ ] jacket like walking with
the swagger like this and [ __ ] and he
walks up to this couple and then
something happens and the guy runs the
boyfriend runs and in he's chasing the
girlfriend across the street I left the
girl the guy left the girl Bravo yeah
and I was just like I would have broke
up with his [ __ ] [ __ ] ass yeah and
then she's like stay away whatever like
and in and then he's yelling and I'm
like that's [ __ ] weird right and I'm
like okay I was far away like it was
like he's like that in my girlfriend
yeah yeah you gotta worry about Jess
I've no no Jess wasn't there but it was
it was it was it was like a good run
like I was I wasn't able to get there
yeah but anyways he was running away
going that way right so I'm like okay
whatever playing with my dogs and then a
dog like Walker comes up he's like hey
man you want someone to walk your dogs
and like we're talking and then while
we're in the middle of conversation when
I sound like a hustler you looking for
somebody to walk your dog yeah yeah I
thought that was the crack brah
I got leashes brah got tags
now he was just trying to he was just
trying to pet my dog he's like he you
you you you you need a dog walker you
know and then like we won't charge for
the second one and we're like talking
and whatever and at the corner of my eye
I see this guy [ __ ] [ __ ] pants
down to his [ __ ] knees and [ __ ] like
don't like that okay like that and then
he's like [ __ ] walking up that's that
walk yeah and then Maddie she starts
barking right she's like barking boo boo
woo and then I see him at the corner
mile I was like oh [ __ ] and then I tell
the dog-walker guy was like hey don't
watch out for this guy this guy's kind
of weird and he's like that your dog is
that your dog and he starts yelling at
me and I'm like what the [ __ ]
so then he runs up and Maddie's like
barking like crazy and he's like looking
at his like he's - Adama [ __ ] you up I'm
a [ __ ] control your dog control your
dog and I was like oh [ __ ] watch out so
then we're like running circles around
this guy and he's chasing Maddie and
he's trying to chase the dog walker he's
trying to chase like you just run it up
and he's like I'll [ __ ] you up and then
the dog walker was like hey man she's
just scared of you he's like what you
want to [ __ ] talk to me and then he's
just trying to fight that guy he's like
oh [ __ ]
and so everybody in the dog parks like
holy [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] nuts right so
we're kind of like doing this thing but
we're just all like oh [ __ ] watch out
right and then Maddie's like running
around him like like a sheepherder dog
just barking and and then he's like
trying to chase the [ __ ] like my dog
and try to fight it and [ __ ] and they
might distract it and there's this lady
with a puppy and a toddler and then
she's stacked like she's standing next
to this other homeless dude that was
just like chillin there but they're
they're talking I think she was like
just watching the whole thing go down he
gets close to her and starts running up
to her oh my gosh the crackhead yeah
yeah so he starts going off [ __ ] you up
to that lame other homeless guy stepped
in he goes not today so no no no they
were both kind of like holy [ __ ] and
she's like holding the baby like she's
like screaming and in so being the other
guy were like oh [ __ ] so we ran up when
I was like hey hey come here come here
[ __ ] you want to fight some
come here come here so I was just trying
to distract them and then he turns
around he's like you want some too when
he turned around you had your key on huh
Redis [ __ ] eyes like he look like a
demon-possessed
oh [ __ ] then we're just trying to like I
was they were like oh [ __ ] cuz we were
just trying to get him away from the
lady so we're like come on come on come
this way come this way and then he's
like oh [ __ ] you up and then so he turns
around thank God he leaves the lady and
then he starts coming up to us but now
he's charging and he's charging he's
like trying to [ __ ] us up and [ __ ] but
he didn't swing or nothin but he was
like getting close and aggressive like
he was just like in are like [ __ ] like
that and I was like okay every time we
run away from him he just charges
forward so I was like what if I just
stood here and see what happened right
so when I just when I just stood
straight like this and I just stared at
him like that
and I was like I'll just [ __ ] kick
his nuts or something oh you're finally
gonna get your wish come true I know so
I stood there like that right and if
Maddie's here barking at him and then so
as soon as I stopped he stopped and and
he just keeps yelling and yelling while
he's like keeping his distance and he's
like pacing back and forth like this and
he starts going back I'll come back and
[ __ ] you up and then he does that and
then I'm just like standing there and
you just stop and if you'll come back
I'll [ __ ] you up
yeah [ __ ] you up that he just goes to
know what this is not fun anymore guys
know what it was fun but now you suck
taste whatever am i yeah and then some
other people came and then they they
kind of helped us out and we just
started like like doing this think I
like like Jurassic Park
creating a perimeter and then that Bulls
like yeah let's invade a Jurassic Park
[ __ ] dude yeah and he was all the way to
the end of the park and then he was just
sitting down while he was talking [ __ ]
to us thank you
yeah and then he got up and he would
like harass people on the street and
[ __ ] it's not that one let that one
white dude that says like [ __ ] you cut
no no that's not
okay it's a it's a it's a black guy and
he looked like a normal yeah he doesn't
look like a bum so he was just so
[ __ ] drugged out that he wasn't in
his head and he was just being so crazy
and violent dude like he was yelling at
tourists and [ __ ] people were walking by
and screaming like you're such a good
guy though cuz like in that situation
you decided to be like hey come here
look at me my story of that would have
ended it to say well cuz dude it was a
lady with the baby and a [ __ ] baby if
she wasn't there
you know what I'd be doing I'll be
[ __ ] running with Mattie dude [ __ ] it
wouldn't even gotten that far like the
moment you said like I saw this dude
yelling across the street my story would
have ended I was gone I woulda been in
the car and I just witnessed it happen
well that's crazy I mean it was so far
that it wasn't like close enough to be
dangerous until like my back was faced
this way and I'm talking and I was like
oh [ __ ] he's coming but it was too late
cuz he was [ __ ] nothing he was
charging 12 not through like JK news
because you know when we used to do
these articles there was a lot of these
situations were in my mind and even said
it out loud like I was stepping but then
you know you start going on in LA a
little more it's like no there's just
too much crazy [ __ ] going on absolutely
I don't many times where I could have
stepped it and I chose not to I'm really
gonna do a bar fight then [ __ ] up
homeless people because they have
superhuman strength when they're on PCP
oh yeah it's just weird like everybody
thinks that they're gonna do something
but when there's like eminent danger in
front of you you don't care and your
first 30 seconds they're just processing
is this happening yeah so people that
think they have that superhero mentality
where they see sunshine Oh Boober it's
like their first 30 second just like
wait is this really happening right now
yeah yeah dude I was just staring at him
and I was telling people don't talk to
him stop cuz it provokes him they didn't
know he was like not there like they
couldn't tell they're like see like in a
suit or something like did he look
proper no I mean he just he just looked
like a retired thug and then but people
didn't know that he was I mean obviously
if he's yelling and he's telling people
he's gonna [ __ ] him up don't tell him
calm down don't tell him anything just
like ignore it and stay away right but
then when they're like hey
you're scaring the dog oh just calm down
man sir be sir calm down like it's like
that's just gonna make him even crazier
how much you wanted that it would have
been a lot easier for them if that dude
was white cuz I don't know man I bet you
because he was black they're like ooh I
don't want to sound racist right now
sorry it's got a alright sort of Scott
cuz there's a little white person they
would have just went off
there's nothing many white people
downtown though yes like the white
people that are dealing with them yeah
there was no yeah there was no white
people wait was a white person and there
was a black dude that's dressed in thug
attire I would be afraid that I will
come off racist you know what I mean
like especially in today's society
telling him to calm down and reward and
his girlfriend was like why she was way
over there exactly I like your people
yeah the lady with the baby was like
Latino and then the bomb was another
like Mexican bomb or whatever there
speaking Spanish together yeah
there were two white bums tow watching
the whole thing go down and endure just
like yeah man but that's the that's the
kind of [ __ ] that I feel like [ __ ] man
la still hasn't changed we're paying a
lot of money to live there cuz that's I
don't think people get how [ __ ]
violent and aggressive are our guys are
like does it make you miss the suburbs
though yeah kind of yeah peaceful in the
suburbs that's why I live in the Deena
homie the D no the South Deena's real
huh me you want to hear this story so
yesterday right Real Talk I was jogging
this do and I once Antony know this dude
got off the way and he said like that
almost real taco made me tear up a
little bit he gave you the sidewalk he
gave me this out and he gave me a thumbs
up tell me I was doing a good job
[ __ ] love probably notice how fat you
used to be
that'd be so funny if he came up he put
my egos I've seen you change or the past
six months
oh my god why I was running just crying
II [ __ ] just run off fast after like
what I did find out because I never
actually uh run the route that I
normally do
I usually just walk that that three mile
route I found out that on the way there
is actually an uphill Oh so when I was
child I was so exhausted but on the way
back malleus fastest [ __ ] dude I was
like lightning dude I was racing this
truck I felt high cuz it was dark to
lose at nighttime I thought the [ __ ]
went through my earphones and [ __ ] I was
so quick man I thought you loved
downhill can we walk around the
neighborhood it feels so good yeah
because it doesn't smell like piss and
[ __ ] and it feels safe buddy super sweet
yeah next time we do it we're just gonna
run back you feel like a superhuman dude
and you run now what the downhill part I
look amazing dude it's like a legit feel
like I should be in the Olympics no joke
it was it's [ __ ] tight the uphill not
so much that's when I stride do kind of
miss living in a suburb though because
of the quiet mm-hmm like there's
non-stop noise there's just like
non-stop like sirens people yelling and
partying but I do not miss how boring it
is like the energy is just so - relaxing
sometimes I like that bonus when we
lived in downtown and you hear the
sirens and all the creative people
yelling crazy [ __ ] yeah one time it was
like 3 a.m. and I just hear a call
I'm like what the [ __ ] is that I look
out and it was a lamborghini aventador
just busting Donuts in the middle
intersectionally well that's kind of
tight but I just wish they did it like
3:00 p.m. yeah but I'm just like [ __ ]
only in downtown like would [ __ ] like
well I like suburbs with neighbors
because if we see that [ __ ] everybody
gets up and they go on the neighborhood
watch out they're like yeah yeah they
say some crazy [ __ ] on that neighborhood
watch out [ __ ] if you like go on the
Facebook room it's tight dude and in a
suburb like if someone was doing that
you need pull out a gun though okay this
guy is just gonna protect this house but
if you pull out a sniper rifle like from
on top of a building oh [ __ ] we got a
shooter on sniper rifle
cuz it's way higher I can't [ __ ] [ __ ]
with my little pistol I'm far you're
enough the space between you and danger
somebody because they need noise like
the movies you know what is here's this
eye so you can hear it more to go you
know the browser got to shut the back
tires and goes forget Bart you know
those [ __ ] neighborhood kids right
dude bars all kinds of messes so we were
out in Yosemite what and we get we were
just about to enter Yosemite right at
this point for about three or four days
you're messed up dude Hika had just
switched out from formula two to milk
the musical chrome boy now like cows
milk cows milk yeah
and that really wasn't sitting right
with his stomach cuz he was like pooping
really hard pebbles so then I was kind
of stressing out over that also his
appetite decreased like crazy and he's
like now a super picky eater which is
all normal for toddlers I read later but
at this point in the trip I'm kind of
really stressed out and I don't realize
it I'm stressing out like I don't I
can't identify when I'm really stressing
out okay being a [ __ ]
without knowing it like like taking out
their anger on you without even knowing
that that's happening oh my god is Nicki
here cuz I think you want to have a bad
day do the same thing that's why that's
funny can I explain it because you're
seeing it in a way that guys won't
understand
I'm sorry guys know what's happening
mother and you're stressed out I was
being a [ __ ] I do know is being a [ __ ]
right stressed out aka a [ __ ] just shut
the [ __ ] up you tell the damn story I'm
listening okay thank you no so at this
point I'm stressed out don't I'm
stressing out unfortunately I'm taking
it out on board aka aka being a [ __ ]
and we were about to enter Yosemite and
yet this one he's already had enough
he's like what the [ __ ] is your [ __ ]
problem I don't know how you really said
it but that was just kind of the the
energy that I felt I was like are you
okay babe are you like what the [ __ ] is
your problem something like I don't know
it could have been that way so it ends
up he gets [ __ ] pissed at me and I'm
getting pissed at him for getting pissed
at me because I don't see it as a
reaction I just see it as his bad
attitude and he's like [ __ ] this we're
not entering [ __ ] Yosemite guys video
somebody
yeah bigad missing yes like you can't
miss it like it's just beautiful giant
rock I mean I miss going there yeah yeah
no I'm saying like because I miss and
you're like you can't miss it I'm like
you can't miss it no you can't miss the
rocks if it's so mad is huge yeah so
we're about to enter there right and
he's like I just posted on my Instagram
I never had a family and I was like
tearing up cuz it was so beautiful he
said we're not gonna [ __ ] into
Yosemite like got pulled over huh well
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] like this so
we're like the entered were like intense
at this point but I yell because Tyco is
right - you had a whisper fight cuz he's
like yeah yeah no he's not sleeping he's
just like that
I like he's really happy and [ __ ] and
he's like [ __ ] you're being [ __ ]
selfish but the knees looking me like
haha the cuts over his head right here
yeah so we're pulled over we can enter
we're both [ __ ] pissed at each other
and whisper [ __ ] fighting we hate
each other at this point and then I'd
have nowhere a [ __ ] family of deer
like beautiful right like super scenic
just crosses right in front of the truck
right so as soon as I see that being the
huge animal of it that I am I'm like
holy [ __ ] like all the pissed off went
away like it was all forgotten the world
is reading it you're a straight simple
no that's how amazing girls I mean that
hormones emotions no were you in a
period they were beautiful it was
[ __ ] like six deer going like this so
you know that you think he was locked in
like [ __ ] I've been looking for
animals the whole trip so he was buried
one you guys have ever seen a piss like
he was at that point yeah like if I
would have said one wrong thing he was
gonna shatter some [ __ ] he's got to run
over the deer and cry about it
[Laughter]
yeah when he calms down that was just
like my child are you happy now I was
already happy right I see these
beautiful deer right in front of the car
and I'm like oh my god there's deer call
it out look they're stared you're scared
oh dear yeah
you didn't even look at the deer he was
like [ __ ] burning burning a hole in
my skull that's all like intense so
they're not even like two minutes later
there's this [ __ ] bears no way yeah
that starts like coming toward our car
and I'm like walking by so now I'm
trying to like come back from like I'm
like oh [ __ ] I was being a [ __ ] I have
to turn the [ __ ] back on right you have
to turn the beach back you have to cuz
your pride said exactly yeah it was an
ego fight for sure
so now my egos back and I'm like what
the [ __ ] I'm like all right well fine
this book can talk about it then eating
honey right or funny Jackie was right
and then I'm like so I have my [ __ ]
eyebrows locked in and then I was like
there's there's a bear right there oh my
god there's a bear and it goes weird
I was a mid-fight an outsider where's
the barrel [ __ ] that's moving oh my oh I
see it it was so beautiful but this will
still like the the Bears are just too
majestic to be pissed I saw the bear
where no he was pissed
it's the one my god ATD moments defuse
it slowly no we had to talk it out and
resolve it and then we got to the bottom
of like him like not not like not
understanding that I'm being stressful
because are stressed out because of
taiga and then it just it was all
resolved and then when it was resolved
we entered and it was nice and then we
started busting up at the fact that we
were falling bridge so stupid he started
I look at the [ __ ] bear but that was
the height we just aren't to fuss no
more laughing or driving later cause
it's like I just reliving like the whole
scene you know my pail is all [ __ ]
funny that's what sucks when you get mad
over petty [ __ ] as you miss out on the
beauty that's happening right now in
front of you but then you guys were
saying that there were no other animals
for the rest of the trend there was
nothing else Jesus Christ coming outside
you'll match he'll do does a baby back
there bro
hey Peters come out I know not enough yo
bear come out eating honey
just roll it on his back to come in
himself I bet you the animals been
trying to cross the street and then
they're like [ __ ] man there's all these
people they're like oh they're fighting
they're distracting those atoms were
like these [ __ ] animals [ __ ]
scream some self-control
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you